okay good afternoon I remembered to
answer two questions that someone had
asked before you had asked about how
does West Nile get transmitted between
birds and I asked Dixon de Pommier who's
the expert and he said birds are very
social and they have virus in saliva so
that's how it goes from bird to bird he
said they've done experiments where
they'll put birds in a closed room and
they'll put some infected birds and some
uninfected and they readily transmit it
okay so that was one the other question
someone asked me is it true that they
put shrimp in the water to get rid of
the mosquitoes so they don't transmit
diseases
I asked Dixon de Paume yay also and he
said shrimp don't eat mosquitoes they're
vegetarians all right so the answer to
that whoever asked me that I don't
remember so you don't put shrimp in
water to get rid of mosquitoes all right
today we're going to talk about
transformation and unko Genesis bianco
Genesis is the development of cancer all
right it means you get a malignant tumor
that is something that whose growth is
not restricted it infiltrates into
surrounding tissues it replaces normal
cells
that's ontogenesis cancer is a genetic
disease after 90 plus years of research
we have finally learned this and in the
genetics of cancer there are commute
ations that affect the way cells
communicate the way they grow the way
they proliferate many other things as
well the way they induce the formation
of blood vessels some of the mutations
are inherited that cause cancer some are
caused by DNA damage environmental
carcinogens and infectious agents which
is what we're going to talk about today
viruses virus induced cancers about 20%
of human cancers viruses are
contributing factors and here are your
viruses
you have a power supply yes thank you
excellent thank you and here are the
seven viruses that participate in human
cancers epstein-barr virus hepatitis B
virus hepatitis C virus
htlv1 human papilloma viruses human
herpes virus 8 and Merkel cell
polyomavirus the latest addition to this
list so these viruses have specific
mechanisms by which they induce cancers
notice HIV isn't on here it doesn't it
doesn't specifically induce cancers the
way we're going to talk about today it
makes cells proliferate because your
immune response makes cytokines that do
that and when cells proliferate they
accumulate mutations
okay so viruses are major causes of
liver cancer and cervical cancer now the
point here to remember is that when
viruses cause tumors they don't need to
do that to replicate it's an accident as
you'll see by the end here it's the side
effects of the hosts response to
infection so here are some other these
are all the known aquagenic viruses
which not only cause tumors in humans
but other animals as well so we have
hepatitis C virus as the retroviruses
also human these are of course both
causing tumors and humans and then a
variety of DNA viruses also causing
tumors and various species adenoviruses
have had naher p's papilloma Polly OMA
and even the pox virus is causing
myxomas and fibromas types of tumors in
animals it all begins in 1909 when
Peyton Rous got a English hen from a
farmer in New Jersey that had a tumor on
it he took out the tumor he grounded up
made of cell-free filtrate this is 1909
we already know about viruses passing
through filters and he injected the
filtrate into another chicken and that
chicken developed the same type of tumor
you know where this work was done by the
way right down the street at Rockefeller
which at the time was Rockefeller
Medical Institute okay so he showed that
cancer could be caused by a viral
infection it took 50 years before this
was appreciated in the intervening time
people were looking for other sorts of
causes of cancer but he eventually got
the Nobel Prize for this 50 over 50
years later in 1966
so his legacy is rouse psycho sarcoma
virus which as you will see gives rise
to two more Nobel Prizes in this story
now if you're interested in cancer I
recommend you read this book just came
out it's called the emperor of all
maladies a biography of cancer by
Siddhartha Mukherjee who is a oncologist
up at Columbia really beautifully
written book and I'm going to give you
three paragraphs from this book to show
you how good it is and also because it
says some of the stuff better than I do
by the 1950s cancer researchers had
split into three feuding camps the
virologist led by Peyton Rous claimed
that viruses cause cancer although no
such virus had been found in human
studies epidemiologists argued that
exogenous chemicals caused cancer
although they could not offer a
mechanistic explanation the third camp
possessed weak circumstantial evidence
that genes internal to the cell might
cause cancer and they will turn out to
be right in this story in 1951 a young
biologist named Howard Temin arrived at
Caltech to study the genetics of fruit
flies Restless and imaginative he soon
grew bored with fruit flies fishing
fields he chose to study Rous sarcoma
virus in Renato de becos laboratory so
here's Howard Temin and here's renato
dulbecco who we've talked about already
for developing the black assay for
animal viruses until the late 50s
Rous sarcoma virus had been shown to
cause tumors only in live chickens
number of starting from that first
experiment of Peyton Rous teman imagined
creating cancer in a petri dish in 1958
in his seventh year in dual Becca
lab Taman succeeded he added Rous
sarcoma virus to a layer of normal cells
in a petri dish the infection of the
cells incited them to grow
uncontrollably forcing them to form tiny
distorted heaps containing hundreds of
cells that teman called fossa the FO
site M and reason represented cancer
distilled into its essential elemental
form cells growing uncontrollably
unstoppably pathological mitosis so this
the kind of nice writing he does he goes
through the whole history of cancer from
the beginning to the present so these
are the fo side that Timmons saw of
cells again these are cells and culture
he infected them with Ralph sarcoma
viruses happened to be avian cells but
the virus will transform other cells as
well here's a focus right here you can
see the mono layer around it as normal
and these cells are elongated they will
pile up you can you can have round fossa
as well such as this one so he said this
is what the virus is doing it's
analogous to what it does in an animal
to make cells devoured uncontrollably by
the 1960s this property was ascribed to
other viruses as well besides brows so
in 1962 polyomavirus was shown to cause
transformation of baby hamster kidney
cells in 1964 sv40 was shown to
transform a mouse cell line in these
experiments most of the cells died but
rare ones who didn't die which didn't
die had different properties they were
transformed that's where the word
transformation come they were
transformed into something different so
the transformation property includes the
LAT loss of anchorage dependence they
don't need a surface for attachment they
will pile up and even grow in the in
suspension they lose contact inhibition
they don't stop growing when they touch
each other as normal cells do they pile
up and they form these fo side which is
what teman first saw in semi-solid media
so if you put if you resuspend the cells
in an auger containing medium such as
you would use to do a plaque assay the
cells will form colonies they will grow
whereas a non transform cell will not do
that
and they also don't need as much growth
to factor in the medium they need less
syrup and you will understand this in a
bit when you see in the case of rouse
and other viruses why the cells are
transformed so those are the properties
of transformed cells and I want you to
remember that transformation in
oncogenesis have really distinct things
okay
transformation occurs in cells in
culture that's what happens when you put
a virus or some other kind of insult
onto a cell that changes their
properties in the ways we've just
described
not that I know of but you could ask
Dixon de Pommier when he comes here at
the end when you find out how this works
maybe you won't want to know the answer
all right so transformation is in sales
and culture
uncle Genesis is a development of a
tumor this happens in an animal and
requires other changes so the virus
makes the first change that transform
cells in order for themselves to form a
tumor then they need five or six or
seven other genetic changes that occur
after the cells growing and growing
unchecked they accumulate mutations and
eventually you get six or seven in very
specific places then you have a tumor so
a transform cell need not be oncogenic
but when we study these cells they
provide insight into what gives us the
genic potential the first step towards
oncogenesis which is transformation no
virus can do it all so when a virus
causes cancer it just begins the process
it doesn't do the rest which is what the
cell does and I think you that's what I
want you to come away with today so how
can a viral infection do this to do to
transform a cell first of all you have
to reduce cytopathic effects or get rid
of them remember a lot of viruses are
cytopathic we don't want the cells to
die otherwise it can't be transformed
because the transform cell is immortal
we have to reduce viral replication or
eliminated completely transform cells
typically do not produce very Ahn's and
the cell has to divide still to make a
focus a transform focus so all of these
events must occur now the first two
conditions you should ring a bell
because they are two of the
characteristics of a persistent
infection go back to the first two
cytopathic effects must be reduced or
eliminated
viral replication must be reduced or
eliminated this one of those are two of
the things you need to have persistent
infections so that's why we say
transformation is a form of persistent
infection so in the in the transform
cell what happens to the viral genome in
some cases there are all or parts of the
genome integrated into the
host genome sometimes there's no viral
nucleic acid in the cell whatsoever and
these were very early observations and
these didn't make any sense because
people thought well how could it be that
the genome sometimes is there and
sometimes it's not we can't make any
sense of this but you'll see how that is
explained in a few moments so if the
transforming infection is not a latent
infection remember a latent infection is
one where the virus infects you make
some virions then no virions are present
then later on at some insult they make
more virions
then they turn it off so the whole
genome is there so it can make very ons
like herpes simplex type one but this is
not the case with this because they
typically don't have but make virus and
they don't even have the complete genome
so they can't make virus so what's going
on here is we're gonna talk about now
for the next 15 minutes or so I want to
explain that to you and this whole route
of understanding how viruses transform
cells took a long time starting from the
1909 experiment that we talked about
with retroviruses and we'll talk about
the studies through the 50s there was
also at the same time in vitro cancer
biology studies people were trying to
understand how cancer arose and then
beginning in the 1920s the studies on
transforming DNA viruses and at one
point all these converges in the 60s and
70s to give us our present theory of not
only transformation but growth control
all of these studies make it made it
really clear to us how growth in cells
is controlled so let's start here with
Rous sarcoma virus how does it cause
tumors and chickens and how does it
transform cells according to Howard
chemins experiment this took over 60
years to sort this out so here's the
start avian Lu kosis viruses a LVS these
are the retroviruses from related to the
ones that rouse found these are endemic
in all chicken flocks throughout the
world no exception these were first
isolated in 1908 these are not
transforming viruses these are just
viruses that in fact chicken they happen
to be retroviruses they're simple
retroviruses they have reverse
transcriptase the inta
eight their DNA into the host cell you
know all of this but what you don't know
is that most chickens are infected with
this virus within a few months of
hatching and this the disease that
results called Lu kosis or leukemia
that's where the name comes from Lu
kosis another name for leukemia occurs
sporadically in infected birds once they
are older than 14 weeks it's about 3%
incidents in a flock they get to keep
leukemia the other 97% of the birds they
make a little virus they have an immune
response they clear the virus and that's
the end of that so this is a very slow
disease to develop it's not an acute
disease and it is not a solid tumor
leukemia is of course a tumor of white
blood cells but it doesn't form a solid
tumor like the sarcoma that rouse cut
off of his chicken and ground up for his
1909 experiment okay so avian Lu kosis
viruses infect all chickens and this is
the this is the pathology or the
pathogenesis now as these birds age if
you live on a farm with lots of birds
you will see other rare cancers occur
you have enough birds you're going to
see these rare cancers and they're often
tumors of connective tissue which is a
sarcoma and of course that's what rouse
studied Rous sarcoma virus these are
solid tumors so what's the relationship
if you isolate virus from these solid
tumors and re-inject them into chicken
they cause solid tumors they don't cause
leukemias and chicken and when they do
cause these solid tumors they do so
rapidly and that's the virus that rouse
isolated Rous sarcoma virus it he got it
from a solid tumor so one of these rare
solid tumors that arise in a farm in New
Jersey and he injected it and the tumor
developed very rapidly in the recipient
his virus grew quite well when other
people subsequently tried to reproduce
his findings they found that most of the
viruses in these tumors were defected
that they couldn't replicate on their
own they needed to have the original ALV
avian lou kosis virus present as a
helper virus and you'll see why in a
moment
okay so rouse was very lucky he isolated
a non defective virus from this chicken
but most of the other ones subsequently
isolate are defective which simply means
that in order for it to grow if you just
inject those into a chicken they will
not cause a tumor unless you put with
them
the original avian blue kosis virus so
what is all this mean what's the
relationship of Rous to a lv and as you
as I've said Peyton Rous was very lucky
but in science that's often what happens
you get lucky and if you quit you're not
gonna get lucky so you have to spend
enough time on something to get lucky
okay so remember a retrovirus life cycle
a LV is a simple retrovirus that the RNA
is copied into DNA it integrates in the
host cell the cell makes mRNAs which
then are translated to make new virion
particles so this all you know now why
does raus but not a lv cause sarcomas
the key finding was that the viral
genomes from the solid tumors that rouse
originally studied our recombinants a
piece of the ALV genome is replaced with
a piece of host DNA this we didn't find
out until 60 years later
so we're fast-forwarding here the DNA
that is in the virus is not random it's
not just any piece of DNA but it encodes
what we now call an oncogene and this
was identified by Michael Bishop and
Harold Varmus
they identified the oncogene and arauz
sarcoma virus in 1976 the original virus
that arouse had isolated they found in
it a gene from chicken cells and they
called that sark sarcoma virus sark and
they both got the Nobel Prize in 1989
for this and that's the first Nobel
Prize after raus to come out of this and
I don't know if I have the other one on
this slide but Howard Temin of course
who originally found out that you could
transform cells in culture with the rous
sarcoma virus subsequently discovered
reverse transcriptase along with David
Baltimore and they both got the Nobel
Prize for that so - two Nobel Prizes
after
on this virus so here's the major
insight that clarified everything so ALV
infected birds as I said come down with
a variety of tumors remember there's a
transient very Mia some of them get
leukemia 3% and then as they age the
others that cleared the virus develop
tumors they cleared the virus but
remember they have Pro viral DNA in them
right the retrovirus has never gone
these rare tumors all contain different
they're all defective and they're all
different browses was the only non
defective one who was very lucky I'll
show you a picture of this which will
make it clearer
so the retroviral genomes which you can
isolate from each tumor so you get
different chickens from different flocks
with tumors solid tumors you isolate
retroviruses they're all derived from a
lv but they're all different because
they've picked up different genes rouses
virus picked up the SARC gene but every
other virus that you pull out of a
sarcoma picks up a different gene and so
we identified many many different
oncogenes in cells by studying these
different bird isolates the goldmine for
molecular oncology so here are some of
these viruses pre-pro viral DNA
sequences here on the left of our avian
retroviruses so here's the original
virus avian Lu kosis virus it's a non
defective virus that infects all
chickens in the world at birth browse
from a solid tumor isolated this virus
right here Rous sarcoma virus you see it
has the SARC gene inserted into it but
the rest of the genome is still fine it
doesn't it didn't lose any viral genes
to acquire this sark gene so it's non
defective so he was really lucky because
everyone else after him who isolated a
virus from a chicken sarcoma isolated
defective viruses which are all listed
below here and each of these have picked
up a different oncogene from the host
cell and you can see they have these
three letter names FIPS nib that's Mik
yes June or rel etc and they're all
cellular genes that have been picked up
by these viruses and as a consequence
they can transform host cell
how that happens we'll talk about but
they've all these viruses have all lost
viral sequence in the process of getting
these cellular oncogenes that's really
important so they can't replicate on
their own they are defective to get
these viruses to replicate you have to
mix them with al V and infect the cell
and then they will replicate so that's
why we call these defective so you see
how lucky rouse was that he got one at
the very start that was none defective
because if he didn't get this he would
not see anything and he would have
stopped the most likely we also have
transducing retroviruses isolated from
mammalian species here these are all
isolated from mice and and primates of
different sorts so for example the
progenitor is murine leukemia virus a
virus found in most mild strains which
is non defective it replicates in mice
causes in leukemia but you can isolate
from mice with various tumors defective
versions that have picked up again
oncogenes from the mouse L Abel Maus RAF
fest films etc here's a sarcoma virus
from sim from monkeys transforming
here's one from cats
okay so different species can do this so
that's what these viruses have done they
picked up cellular sequences and that
was that is what make them transform now
don't get the impression that all
retroviruses can transform cells for
example the lentiviruses that we talked
about last time
these are cytopathic they kill cells
they cannot transform them because they
kill them but the viruses we've talked
about rouse ALS and in the mouse
leukemia viruses they do not kill cells
so they have the potential to transform
them the other thing which to clarify
for you if you don't understand the idea
of defective versus non defective
retroviruses one more time a defective
virus is missing some part of the genome
so it needs a helper to produce that
part in order to produce more virus and
typically these viruses are missing
envelope glycoproteins and these get
deleted during the process of oncogene
capture and that's why they're defective
now this slide shows
two mechanisms for the capture of
oncogenes by viruses I don't want you to
learn this it is just to show you
because I'm sure you're thinking how
does a virus capture an oncogene we
don't really understand but there's
there two hypotheses shown here and
since the neither have been proven
there's no need for you to understand
but basically you remember that viral
DNA integrates into the DNA of the host
cell and it does so almost randomly and
at some point it's going to integrate
next to an oncogene and when oncogene is
we will learn shortly is a gene with
various functions in the cell that can
kick that cell to divide uncontrollably
under certain conditions and when I
explain to you what these oncogenes are
you'll understand that but randomly in a
retrovirus integrate next to one of
these oncogenes and then when the viral
RNA is produced sometimes it's just
plain old var wild-type viral RNA but
rarely the polymerase may transcribe the
the downstream oncogene which is what
you see here this will then get packaged
into the virus particle so now you have
one RNA with a little bit of oncogene
fuse to the virus RNA in one wild-type
and then during infection of the new
cell what we think is that there's some
recombination events that occur which
eventually make the virus that that
comes out have a copy of both copies of
aren't the provirus that integrates is
now bringing in the cellular oncogene
okay so starting from this original
integration event you have production of
new virus particles that carry an
oncogene and an infection of a new cell
that oncogene is transmitted now
sometimes what happens is additional
mutations or changes occur in this
oncogene and for some of the
retroviruses this is very important so
you can see this light colored sequence
here on the bottom means that the
original monka gene has changed in some
way so in some in many yes
it is not it does not happen all the
time it's a relatively rare event which
is why transformation it took the
original the generation of the original
transforming virus is a rare event and
that probably reflects that this
read-through doesn't occur all the time
and because because the LTR the virus
has transcriptional stop sequences that
should stop it but sometimes a mistake
is made but the selection for the
oncogene is so powerful that is it
transforms cells and initiates tumor
formation that it's very easy to see so
these viral oncogenes that are picked up
the ones that we've talked about so far
roust arrived are not precise copies
they're either mutated or overexpressed
forms of the normal cellular genes
because that gene is in the cell if it's
there why doesn't it transform the cell
well because the virus takes it out of
either mutates it or over expresses it
and that is what does that's when the
problems arise these oncogenes are
normal cellular genes that are involved
in cellular growth regulation and the
cell genes are often called proto
oncogenes these are these are genes that
control the cell cycle and in fact they
were discovered by virtue of being
oncogenes we learned about all aspects
of control of cell growth by studying
these oncogenes picked up by
retroviruses so oncogenes in the virus
now our mutant proto-oncogene the
proto-oncogene is what is in the cell
the retrovirus picks it up and now
becomes a Honka gene so basically if a
proto-oncogene is either expressed at
the wrong time or if they are mutated so
that they are on or off the cell grows
without regulation so now the virus has
taken a cell a normal cell gene is
either mutated it or is expressing it at
the wrong time and that is what causes
cellular transformation proto-oncogenes
of course this is what's in the cell and
this is what was hypothesized
years ago by many cancer biologists say
since there's some Celgene that's gone
wrong but they didn't have any evidence
for it and viruses gave them that
evidence so proto-oncogenes are found in
all cell and there can involve din the
control of cell growth they are highly
regulated because you you want to
regulate cell growth you're over 60 of
them now known and they have these three
letter names as we said and then the
cellular genes have a C in front of them
the normal cellular counterparts EOCs
C mix CMOS C wrasse so the wrasse or the
Sark protein would have a C in front of
it and then the retroviruses that carry
the altered companies you put a V in
front of it V McVie ma severus V Sark
so that Sark gene identified by Bishop
and Varmus
in the virus has a normal cellular
counterpart there are five major classes
of proto oncogenes again these are the
normal cell genes that have been picked
up and sent wrong by the retroviruses
one is is those encoding extracellular
growth factors so these are growth
factors that the cell normally needs to
tell it when to divide then of course
growth factors work via receptors the
growth factor binds a receptor and
initiates signaling Cascades which
stimulates cell growth there are
intracellular signal transducers these
transmit the signal started by the
growth factor receptor and transmit the
signal into the nucleus to kick cell
division how do they work they will
interact with nuclear transcription
proteins that regulate expression of
genes that are needed for cell division
and finally there are tumor suppressor
genes these are genes that are negative
regulators of cell growth now these are
not picked up by retroviruses these were
identified in the DNA tumor viruses
which we will see so these four classes
were picked up in retrovirus so this
defines a signaling cascade from the
growth from the growth
factor in the medium all the way down
into the nucleus to stimulating cell
growth so here's a diagram of how this
works
so here all the so you basically can
make an oncogene out of any of these
components of this signaling pathway so
growth factors we know of oncogenes that
are growth factors the receptors for
these growth factors we know a number
which are also all genes they've been
picked up by retroviruses and can
transform cells membrane bound protein
kinases G proteins such as wrasse
cytoplasmic protein kinases and finally
transcriptional regulators in the
nucleus so again this is a pathway that
tells the cell to divide there's a
growth factor present the binds a
receptor and it starts this signaling
cascade the cell eventually divides and
this is this cascade is divided into
discrete steps there are proteins at
every step that have a function and
retroviruses can pick up any of these
genes and alter them in a certain way
such that they're always active and when
they reintroduce into the cell by the
retrovirus the cell divides
uncontrollably so for example you don't
have growth factors around all the time
but with a mutant growth factor brought
in by retrovirus you do you have a
growth factor present all the time and
it's making the cells divide so that's
what transforms the cells uncontrolled
cell growth cell shape change loss of
adhesion is by a retrovirus bringing
into a cell an altered form or an over
expressed form of one of these critical
proteins oncoproteins so again this
these whole pathways were really sorted
out by using these genes discovered in
transforming retroviruses so in the cell
these genes are under strict control as
you might imagine because the cell
should not be dividing all the time most
of ourselves in fact they're not only
under certain conditions should they
divide and they can be activated such
that they're out of control by several
ways you can have mutations in the gene
encoding the growth factor or the
receptor or whatever the signaling
protein is
you can have loss of expression
regulation so in a retrovirus maybe a
protein the gene encoding a protein is
next to a promoter that is very strong
and is on all the time whereas normally
in the South the promoter would be
regulated so the it's no longer
regulated when it's brought in by a
retrovirus so these are dominant ways of
messing up the regulation of these
oncogenes there are also negative or
recessive regulators and these are
mutations and tumor suppressor genes
okay so normally these genes block the
formation or block the progression of
cell division they negatively regulate
cell division well everything we've
talked about up here the growth factor
pathways positively regulate growth
growth they push cells to grow the tumor
suppressor genes negatively retro they
focus on cell growth and mutations in
those genes will now allow cells to
multiply uncontrollably and I said I
said these were discovered with the DNA
viruses okay so to to understand how
this works we need to remember the cell
cycle that cells undergo and there are
key control points so there are for
example the proto oncogenes that we've
talked about act at g0 the they push
cells into the rest of the cycle they
push cells through mitosis through
growth phases through DNA synthesis
phases and eventually back through cell
division there are checkpoints here that
the tumor suppressor genes engage so
here if conditions aren't right in the
cell if there is DNA damage or if
there's a viral DNA in the cell these
tumor suppressor genes will stop cell
division as a kind of defense and if you
have mutations in these tumor suppressor
genes you don't have that functionality
any longer and the cells will go through
the stop checkpoint so again these were
these tumor suppressor genes these
negative regulators were revealed in DNA
viruses and the retrovirus has revealed
these dominant oncogenes that push the
cells through the growth cycle
now retroviruses remember the ones that
put in a positively acting uncle gene
deuce they transform cells in three ways
one involves rapid tumor formation and
this is like Rous sarcoma virus
typically two weeks or so
Ralph's carries an activated oncogene
has a mutation in it that makes the
protein constitutively active it's not
regulated anymore it's a dominant
oncogene when the virus comes in to sell
this protein is produced the cells start
to multiply uncontrollably they cannot
be checked because of this mutant growth
factor so that's one and then there's
intermediate kinetics of tumor formation
that is a V and Lu kosis virus remember
some of the chickens many months after
being infected they developed tumors
this virus doesn't have a dominant V onk
what happens with these al V's to cause
these cirrhotic tumors is that they
integrate next to an oncogene and turn
on its uncontrolled expression so they
don't capture it they integrate next to
it in the genome and turn it on when it
shouldn't be okay so that's a sis
activation mechanism and finally you
have slow kinetics of tumor formation
this is typical for htlv human t-cell
leukemia virus years it takes years to
get tumors form htlv like a lv carries
no dominant oncogene but it also does
not integrate into anka genes in our
genome but rather it makes a protein
that is a transcriptional activator that
then goes in the cell and activates the
production of growth factors that push
the cell to divide uncontrollably okay
so three mechanisms you inappropriately
express a growth control protein you
integrate next to a growth control
protein resulting in it's an appropriate
expression or you make a protein that
makes transcripts of that growth control
protein and so we have based on those
three we have three kinds of
transforming retrovirus
we have Trent what we call transducing
retroviruses these pick up a normal
cellular gene by that mechanism I showed
you before and they either make
mutations in it or a fuse it's a viral
gene they make an altered protein with
abnormal properties so this is like raus
then we have sis acting retroviruses
they integrate next to an oncogene so
the downstream LTR the one on the right
of the genome has a powerful promoter in
it it also has enhancers
this integrates next to some cellular
gene if it happens to be an oncogene
involved in growth control that
integration turns on the expression of
that oncogene uncontrollably and then
finally we have the trans activating
retroviruses slow inducers of tumors
they express a transcriptional activator
protein like htlv-1 and they turn on
cellular growth genes so they stimulate
the production of proteins that
shouldn't be produced they stimulate
cell division so three distinct
mechanisms and three kinds of
retroviruses so here are some discreet
some diagrams of these it's the same
thing that I've just told you on the
last two slides that's shown as a
picture three different kinds of
retroviruses the first is transducing
here the virus has picked up from the
cell in the previous growth cycle and
oncogene in this case it is integrated
into the host genome it produces this
oncogene which then pushes the cell to
divide uncontrollably there are no
controls on the production of this
oncogene as there are on the normal
cellular version or there are mutations
in it that make it constitutively active
we have the sis activating retroviruses
they integrate next to an oncogene and
transcription initiated at the LTR
produces inappropriately the oncogene
uncle protein and finally the trans
activating retroviruses they integrate
they produce viral trans activators that
activate the transcription of of
cellular genes okay so those are the
three mechanisms of by which
retroviruses transform cells what you
should also remember is that these
viruses tramps transform cells as a
mistake
they don't have to do this they pick up
jeans or they insert next to jeans by
accident that's not a part of their life
cycle they don't need to pick up an
oncogene in order to replicate there is
no obvious requirement for
transformation or oncogenesis for the
survival of retroviruses or their
evolution ok so just really remember
that it's an it's a mistake it's an
accident that retroviruses transform
cells it's not part of their life cycle
ok let's talk about the DNA viruses now
how this revealed more about cell cycle
regulation the first oncogenic DNA virus
discovered in 1933 by Richard Shope
these were papilloma viruses small
viruses with double stranded DNA genomes
they caused warts in cottontail rabbits
and Richard Shope also worked at the
Rockefeller Institute
Ludwig growth's discovered polyomavirus
in 1953 these cost tumors in certain
kinds of animals rare tumors also in
1962 Eddie and Helaman showed that sv40
they actually discovered sv40 as a
contaminant of the early polio vaccines
which were produced in monkey cells
which happened these monkeys happen to
be infected with sv40 and they showed
that these viruses these are monkey
viruses caused rare tumors and numeron
hamsters as a side it turns out that
many people got sv40 in their polio
vaccines in the early days of
immunization but so far there's no
evidence that any tumors have resulted
so the classic DNA tumor viruses sv40
which I've just described to you it's
natural host is the monkey it does not
cause tumors in the monkey it does not
transform monkey cells it will transform
other species of cells so really calling
it a tumor virus is a bit of a stretch
because in its natural host it doesn't
cause tumors but it does cause tumors in
some animals so the name has stuck
polyomavirus another similar virus
this one is from mice very similar to
sv40 except from the mouse no role in
mouse cancer but it will make tumors in
different animals
hamsters rats and rabbits so all this is
important why it's not causing tumors in
the original house it will be clear in a
moment so here is what happens to cells
of different species when you infect
them with either sv40 or mouse
polyomavirus if you take a monkey you
and fix effect with us before the
monkeys permissive it's the natural host
Mouse polyomavirus monkey cells are not
permissive if you take s before he does
not infect mouse cells will infect sorry
well no it's not infect mouse cells will
infect monkey sorry hang on I'm just
looking at s v40 is the monkey virus it
will not replicate in Mouse cells of
course it will replicate what whereas
polyomavirus will replicate in those
cells and hamster and rat cells are semi
permissive for both viruses okay well
these cells are susceptible which means
of course that they have receptors and
permittivity of course means being able
to make new variants semi permissive
means you only get early proteins made
no virions so the this summer a year is
that tumors occur only in semi
permissive species in other words sv40
and mouse volume do not cause tumors in
their natural hosts only in hamsters and
rats which is not their hand natural
host why is this and this is the key
here here are some more observations we
need to know if you infect a 100,000
cells with sv40 or poly OMA rat hamster
you get one transform focus so it's very
rare it's not a normal part of the
lifecycle so what does this mean so this
is just a review of poly ouma's in case
you have forgotten them they're small
DNA viruses double-stranded DNA rather
short icosahedral capsids and sv40 as i
have told you is a monkey virus there
are also human viruses one is called BK
associated with some tumors and Jace
which apparently infects most of us and
I think Saul has talked about that
papillomaviruses are also DNA tumor
viruses remember the shope papilloma
virus and rabbit it's the first
papilloma virus now we have many human
papilloma viruses over 100 serotypes
some of which are responsible for
cervical cancers and other cancers as
well a third type of DNA tumor virus is
the adenovirus these are larger
double-stranded DNA viruses bigger DNA
more proteins many human serotypes
they do not cause cancer in humans but
they can cause tumor in hamsters so this
has also been informative in
understanding the basis of tumorigenesis
and like Paulie OMA and papillomas these
are rare events only one focus when you
add a lot of virus to cells okay so
those are the three kinds of DNA tumor
viruses we're going to talk about now to
summarize what we've learned about
growth control so viruses from these
families cause rare tumors and rare
transforming events in certain cell
types and a key discovery was the
finding of tumor antigens so when
animals are infected by these tumor
viruses they make proteins in the tumor
tissue and these antibodies were used to
define what kinds of proteins are
present and in cells when you transform
cells with these virus they make the
same protein so they were called T
antigens or tumor antigens and you've
heard these before in the context of DNA
replication when you transform cells
with these DNA viruses and look for
viral DNA what you find is that most of
the viral DNA is not present all that
you can find in many cases is DNA
encoding the T antigen these proteins
originally described as present in
tumors and transform cells so this is
very different from transformation by
retroviruses where a lot of the genome
is still present so these are the T
antigens among between the sv40 poly
Oma's and pap
viruses so you've heard about some of
these before sv40 poly Ouma there are a
couple of different sizes there's large
and small T large middle and small T and
they're all dis sv40 and mouse versions
are all different
okay so sv40 has its own set of t
antigens and poly Ouma has its own set
for the papilloma viruses they have
three they're encoded by e5 e6 and e7
genes they're all early proteins
adenovirus also has T antigens they're
called a1 a and E one be all different
papilloma adenovirus all different
proteins but they all have the same
function as you will see or similar
functions in in regulating cell growth
now these are essential viral genes
they're absolutely required for
replication and they also activate
transcription this was discussed in two
previous lectures they're needed for
viral DNA synthesis and again they are
the only viral genes that are always
present in tumor cells either in an
animal or in a transformed cell in the
culture so the genes for the T engine
are the only ones that are consistently
present so why are they there are they
the cause of transformation or the
effect of it two key observations that
led to the answering this question first
of all T antigen is essential for DNA
replication you learned that already and
T antigen alone can transform cells in
fact we use T antigen in the lab if we
want to immortalize cells from an animal
we put T antigen in them and it could
come from any of these viruses and those
cells will divide forever and become
immortalized so T antigen is enough
now remember s before he doesn't encode
DNA polymerase it depends on the host
cell DNA polymerase in order to
replicate if you remember T antigen
recruits the polymerase to the origin in
addition T sv40 wants the cells to be
dividing to be able to replicate in it
yeah so that it it moves the cells into
the g1 and s phases it wants actively
replicating DNA so they can use the
polymerase
so in addition number of years later it
was found that a cell protein of about
53 killa Dalton's bound to sv40 t
antigen this is called p53 that's fact
number one fact - transcription of
adenovirus early genes which includes
the T antigens of adenovirus requires a
cell protein called e to F these are
transcription proteins are now called
the e to F family of transcription
proteins so these are required for early
adenovirus mRNA synthesis and finally
fact 3 e to F 1 of the transcript
cellular transcription proteins was
found to be bound to another cell
protein called the retinoblastoma
protein or R be so retinoblastoma
protein was originally identified in I
tumors in children it turns out that
these three proteins p53 are B and E 2 F
are critical players in regulating the
cell cycle now remember the growth
factors and the proteins in the growth
factor pathway that are picked up by
retroviruses are crucial for pushing the
cell into division these regulate the
cell cycle whether or not they're going
to route the cells will respond to those
growth factors ok again we look at the
cell cycle here the beginning mitosis is
at the top here of course we have cell
growth replication of DNA and then cell
division ok so this is what we're
talking about here we're talking about
retroviral picked up proteins that send
signals for this cycle to begin and then
regulatory proteins that decide whether
to accept those signals are not so
here's the link between all of these RB
and p53 are negative regulators those
are the ones I told you about at the
very beginning they stop cells from
cycling when the conditions are not
right
they're the brakes for the cell cycle
engine so the angka deactivated
oncogenes from the retrovirus identify
and retroviruses say to the cell cycle
let's go and RB and p53 say wait let's
make sure that conditions are right
is everything okay can we do this and if
it's not right they put a brake on what
it what the signals that the growth
factors have sent in that's why they're
called tumor suppressor genes so I think
you can begin to see now why mutations
in these genes would also cause
transformation as well now a go/no-go
decision to turn on the cell cycle is
determined by growth factors in the
medium basically is the outside world
rich enough to replicate the cell and
those growth factors in the medium
they're all encoded by oncogenes
that were picked up by retroviruses
that's how they were identified and the
whole pathway leading from the growth
factor all the way into the nucleus all
the steps were oncogenes identified in
retroviruses now if conditions are not
right
these RB and p53 proteins pause the cell
cycle at the restriction point the cell
doesn't make DNA and does not divide so
let's go back to the cell cycle picture
here's the restriction point in g1 so
there may be signals for this cycle to
begin two cells to enter g1 but if p53
and RB figure that conditions aren't
right they will stop the cell cycle
right here they will enough not allow
DNA to replicate and cells will not
divide until conditions are right and
the protein that regulates one of the
proteins that regulates this is our B
and as I said this was identified in
children with retinal tumors this is a
recessive oncogene these kids have to
have mutations in both copies of the RB
gene in order to get a retinal tumor and
this was sorted out many years ago so
let's look at a simple might of genetic
activation of cell cycle progression so
these component of these components are
oncogenes that were identified in
transforming retroviruses so you have
this is a cell here the plasma membrane
the nucleus is down here and here is a
growth factor receptor so you have
growth if you add
growth factors to the medium these are
the ligands here in yellow they will
bind the receptor you then start a
phosphorylation cascade through grass
proteins and a number of cases all of
which end up raising the level of
cyclones in the nucleus the Cyclones
phosphorylate RB protein or lead to the
phosphorylation of RB protein and that
blocks its negative regulation of the
cell cycle the cells can now go from G 1
into s alright so here you have you had
growth factors the transduction cascade
goes ends up in the nucleus RB is
phosphorylated growth can begin now how
does that work how does RB control
growth RB as I told you before binds the
e to F family of proteins the e to F
family are transcription proteins that
in turn are needed for the production of
mRNAs that encode proteins needed to go
through the cell cycle ok so these are
some of these e2f dependent genes are
absolutely required to start S phase so
RB is usually bound to these proteins
which blocks them from activating so RB
is negatively regulating the ability to
start S phase of the cell cycle when you
phosphorylate RB by the cell cyclin
dependent kinases which we showed in the
previous slide these guys down here in
the nucleus these phosphorylate RB when
our B is phosphorylated it gets released
from the e to F proteins and then e to F
can go to their target genes make the
mRNAs and then the cell can leave one p
g1
and move into s so that's how in a
simple way how RB controls the cell
cycle if it's phosphorylated that means
that conditions are right there are
growth factors present and that the cell
can divide but if there aren't any
growth factors present for example RB
will not be phosphorylated it will stay
bound to these e2f proteins and you will
not get entry of the cell into s
now of course DNA viruses want the cell
to be an S phase right because they need
especially those small DNA viruses they
need the cell to be actively making DNA
so that it can use the DNA polymerase
and that's where T antigen comes into
effect T antigen by itself kicked cells
into S phase T antigens bind RB that
releases e to F proteins and initiates s
transcription so the normal pathway in
the cell is that phosphorylate RB is
associated from E to F what the T
antigens do is to bind RB and take it
away from you to F they want to do this
because they want the cell to be
actively dividing they don't want to
transform the cell that's an accident -
they want the cell to divide so they
sequester our V so that the cell can
kick into the S phase so this is a
schematic of how this works
so normally RB is bound here's our B
this yellow guy here is bound to the e
to F family of proteins and that blocks
them from acting
if you phosphorylate RB you dissociate
it from E to F so E to F is the pink guy
here
it's a complexes of other proteins as
well but the point is phosphorylation of
RB separates it so that now e to F can
go on to its target genes and initiate
DNA synthesis if you introduce T
antigens to this equation e 1 al large T
or e 7 the T antigens from three
different kinds of DNA transforming
viruses those T antigens will bind RB so
the effect is the same as to
phosphorylate it it releases e to F so e
to F can now go on to its target genes
so to remember it's a transcription
factor and those gene products are then
needed to kick the cell into S phase so
the viruses want to do this again to
have DNA polymerase actively dividing
cells so the t antigens bypass normal
cell regulatory can
trol of RB phosphorylation the viruses
want to do this so they can replicate
they're not meaning to transform the
cell there is another step of control
here whether to go through the cell
cycle into acid and that is regulated by
p53 the other protein that binds T
antigens if there's DNA damage in the
cell or unscheduled DNA synthesis like
viral DNA synthesis p53 can detect this
in ways we don't have time to get into
but if p53 detects one of these two
conditions it says we are not going into
s and there's a whole other mechanism
for that that we won't go into but just
like RB can block cells from going into
s p53 can also it just has different
inputs p53 is looking at DNA damage or
viral DNA synthesis so p53 as I said
recognizes DNA damage it recognizes
viral DNA s as abnormal cell DNA's are
fine but it sees viral DNA replication
it says this is not a good idea if e to
F happens to be free remember that can
happen if either RB is phosphorylated or
bound by T antigens then e to F plus p53
induce apoptosis this is how p53 is
putting the brakes on the cells or one
of the ways it induces apoptosis
it's got free RB and free e to F
essentially and the cells die and
remember a lot of DNA viruses do what to
apoptosis they block it right this is
why because p53 is messing it with it
and pushing the cells into apoptosis of
the DNA viruses no no we need to
replicate in these cells so they inhibit
apoptosis so that that is the link
between these two aspects of infection
infected cells enter S phase because T
antigen counter the RB checkpoint and
infected cells don't die because p53
isn't activated by T antigen
okay so that's what the tea antigens do
they counter RB and they counter p53
which are both gatekeepers of the cell
cycle they want the cell to go into s so
they can have good DNA replication
conditions
two more mysteries so why are all the
viral genes except the T antigens
deleted or turned off and why is
transformation so inefficient
well transformation is rare because you
need to low probability events to occur
first of all you can't express the
lethal eight genes of these viruses all
the genes that make capsids and cause
the cells to to lyse so you either have
to have a deletion of late genes or the
virus infect semi permissive cells where
late gene expression is blocked so now
you remember these viruses only
transform cells that are semi permissive
the wrong species and this is why
they're able to transform them because
they don't go into late viral DNA late
viral gene expression so the cells are
not killed and they can instead be
transformed in addition they have to
give T antigen to every cell that that
is produced from the original one so the
DNA encoding T antigen has to be
integrated into the host DNA so this is
also a rare event the integration of T
antigen because that has to be inherited
by all the subsequent cells because if
they don't have T antigen what is going
to happen are B and p53 are going to be
active again and they're going to stop
unscheduled entry into s okay so that's
why transformation is rare you can't
have lytic replication so you have to
transform only non-permissive cells you
have to prevent a late gene expression
and you have to have T antigen in every
cell which means it has to integrate
which is also a rare event so again just
like transformation by the retroviruses
transformation and to information there
are and that's why I say DNA tumor virus
is a stretch because in their normal
hosts they don't cause tumors they cause
tumors in their and and and what are not
their natural hosts because of the
aberrant conditions that arise semi
permissive replication in the rare
integration of T antigen coding
sequences into the genome none of that
is needed for the normal life cycle and
all you need to do is look at a
permissive cell where these viruses
replicate quite well by our lytic they
don't cause too much
they don't transform cells this is an
accident yet it's been it for us it's
been an informative accident and I think
this is one of the beauties of science
where you take an accident a virus
transforming the wrong cell and you
pursue it you know can you imagine just
think if you said well I'm gonna study
rare transformation of hamster cells
with a human virus that doesn't cause
tumors and humans just think how someone
would react to that if they didn't
really understand what was going on you
have to be very persistent yet that kind
of study led us to understand how
transformation occurs so sometimes you
have to pursue what seemed like odd
things in order to understand what's
going on
but if you remember one thing today just
remember that the transformation of
cells by either retroviruses or these
DNA viruses is not part of the normal
life cycle it is an accident but for us
as I said it's been a beneficial
accident another way to look at it is
that transformation is an epiphenomenon
of a unique life cycle as I've said many
times the DNA viruses have to interfere
with the cell cycle they have to kick
the cell into s so that they make DNA
and probably all DNA viruses do this
except poxviruses you know why
poxviruses might be the exception I
think we've talked about that actually
here but they use their own they encode
their own Plumer they don't care what
the cell is doing and there are also
very big viruses that me me viruses
which been recently discovered I should
probably ask add this to this slide
they also encode their own DNA synthetic
machinery so they don't have to do that
they have to start the cell synthetic
machinery needed to make DNA and just to
review T antigens turn on the cell cycle
by an activating p53 and RB now the
retroviruses remember turn on the cell
cycle by mimicking the growth factor
stimulatory pathway and then RB and p53
don't seem to sense that anything is
wrong there's no unscheduled DNA
synthesis there cuz it's a retrovirus
but in the case of these DNA viruses
they're acting right at the cell cycle
checkpoints p53 and RB remember these
are negative regulators which mean their
breaks if you break the breaks which is
what the DNA tumor viruses do then the
cells replicate uncontrollably and as we
said if the cells initiate apoptosis p53
binding to e to F the viral genomes have
encoded ways to get around that and they
don't want to do this to transform cells
they want to do it to replicate their
genomes so all of this leads to
transformation of cells but remember a
transform cell is not a tumor cell you
need more mutations in that genome of
that cell to make it a tumor cell as
I've said if there is one mutation here
say in a growth factor that leads to
retroviral transformation you typically
need five or six or seven more before
that cell will become a tumor cell those
mutations accumulate by virtue of the
cell replicating uncontrollably the
virus now has nothing to do with it any
longer its stimulated the cell to divide
now the cell is sort of in charge of
itself and mutations are accumulating
and when the right ones occur in the
right genes then the cell becomes a
tumor cell so in the early stages of a
tumor inside of us initially it's a
transformed cell that has altered growth
properties and probably many of those
never develop beyond that
but if they keep multiplying and they're
not cleared and they accumulate
mutations they will eventually grow
uncontrollably metastasize be able to
direct blood flow to the tumor all these
properties are caused by other mutations
the virus has just started they're on
their way to becoming cancer cells so I
want you to also remember that it
transform cells not cancer cell the
virus just initiates this
you